Hello minna-san konnichiwa
Everybody it looks like I'm wearing the same outfit as yesterday, which if-it's crazy
And it doesn't make any sense we're gonna finish the game now all right Mitch Conner is everywhere. I'm Mitch Conner. It's great again.
I am - I might be crazy here
But I do think Mitch Conner represents some form of American politician
Nope actually we can just walk in
Mitch Conner is great again
Are they still talking about the gay fish? No okay? Just making sure they just seem traumatized. They've been there for a week
All right all right all right well
It doesn't look bad everywhere, so I think we might be all right all right all right. All right all right all right?
Oh right? Oh right? Oh right? Oh, right? Oh, right? Oh, right? Oh right? Oh right? Oh right or now ten-eighty move your hips
No, okay cool all right good talk yeah
It's the Trump supporters everybody
People like change don't they?
That's almost like real life
Except, we can go back in time
we can fix this
I'm Morgan Freeman
You're farts seemed to have blasted a ripple in space-time continuum
that's right, my name is
Morgan Freeman here's a picture of
Hanabi Walt's very nice Hanabi which of course means fireworks
So they are dancing underneath the fireworks
Coonstagram
Can't believe we haven't really like paid attention to this because it's super fun like there's pictures of stuff, okay some stuff
Hashtag freedom pals. Isn't that cute? it's a bit immersive in a weird way
Yeah, just me am I talking to an empty audience here, huh has everyone left you need you didn't care about the ending?
Okay, let's be really you're not that pretty plus, you're eight, so I shouldn't be judging you
okay great glad, we got that out of the way
Excuse me I had a soda
for lunch
Okay, now you know that, isn't this great you learn new things every day or thank God. We're here.
A ZINGY TINGY TITTY
Oh myyyy
*breathes heavily*
It sounds good, I wanna eat it
I understand
Ah look we took a picture with Morgan Freeman
No we should just go I don't think ready to eat the seven-layer quesarito Chipotle beefy nacho supreme. Yes, I'm Morgan Freeman
So what what makes you so farty about burritos
I thought it was the being back in time to before Mitch Conner was sworn into office
You can do it. You just have to believe in yourself. You just have to believe the classic storytelling
You just have to believe oh
Excuse me
Intentional oh my god, it's so awkward
Earless all right Bruce it's stronger than any bird over leash it
I forgot about the believing in herself bet I guess oh, no you didn't believe harder now
Well where well I wonder where we went probably scarcer oh, it's Christmas
It wasn't that bad with Mitch Conner
That roller coaster
Listen it's not that simple. I didn't believe in myself. How do I believe myself when everyone is so mean to me?
The fractured, but Hall, that's
Ridicu place on Christmas oh yeah cuz that because mr.. Hankey comes out
On the lawn for its creatures
Oh
Yes yes
Woodland critters and we're gonna find out I think so
Defeat the woodland critters. Oh wow
Oh, they have a lot of help dude oh, no
No more dark meat
Or not
What are we gonna do
Yes of course
But oh yeah, I am a Christian okay, let me just charge these prayers
hashtag thoughts and prayers
I'm working on it. Thank you very much and
Aren't you Jewish shut up. I'm trying
All right, I'm almost am I'm I just got a praise a little bit. Oh there we go
It's Jesus Christ and he's God
All right Santa
Now are we gonna fight him as
What's happening bet okay
We weren't expected Santa to show up whatever will we do?
We're in a bit of a bind rabid II don't be sad Barry shucks. I can just sacrifice myself. No no oh
Okay, all right. Well why not?
No, I think about it
Oh, he sacrificed himself and now they all Saturdays with us excellent. Okay. Well let's begin on this
420 baby
That's my season oh
Boy, I'm going to do Shakespeare
You know we don't do a lot of damage do we okay this might be it I'm gonna block this attack
I hate her she says that all the time whatever you just did naked
Yes of course
All rights going down very slowly
It's time for diabetes, baby
Can only really do this one?
They can heal each other Lucifer loves you she meets
Yeah, alright alright well at least we have a chance now before I was like a little worried
What else does Santa have he has he can create a gingerbread
That looks terrible, but okay
Okay now let's finish this Jim
Hey you came track any very nice
Okay, all right. I get it guys. I get it your your rebels. I appreciate it. Let's confuse this guy
Hahaha
And we got it already hopefully he's confused come on no well he attacks a friend is well, I guess
Chapelle okay, man I
Want a place in Poe
I think they released an app actually from her phone destroy or something like that. I need to check it out alright
I hopefully that did something Adam
Hey, yeah, that's good kills two of them, okay
mam ma looks like
What is he healing
Sorry but that ya know it's your turn, this is a junior junior man even do anything
And he's down. I always feel bad for killing the Christmas critters. They're so cute
Oh
I don't know if you can reach all the way oh
You can awesome I am out of luck nigga oh
Look at that that was awesome
We got two attacks with Santa you're gonna
Thank You Shannon
Give me that we technically killed your reindeers. Oh, he was crying one of them
That's okey. Hey we got a new did we get another one then
Or we might I think we're on this
Sorry why are we going to?
rock pit rock beats paper Mitch win sides actually
Not bad not bad now listen boys and girls. This is said this is etem
We need to max out all our skills. Okay, all right. Okay, all right, okay? I think okay
I think actually oh wait. What is this we got this one?
Look at that. It's very powerful very Marie forbidden very nice
Yes
Yes, oh
Okay, and then I just said hold on there now on one second there
Any outfit that we haven't cried wait you can find them in efforts
Tell you now Mitch Conner Barlow
Here we are at the unplanned Parenthood right before Christmas
Portions, we need a doctor to look at our friends asshole lemme guess has got a big crack down the middle ha ha
The mayor has to be stopped we know how to do it the mayor
That scumbag made that town that shit always today. We can put a stop to it. Please just look at our friends
Just look at it. Oh here it is
I'm glad there's the title actually made sense ah the sphincter trying to take us back
Are you ready for this you can do it you hit
Well it didn't work the first time, so I don't know why
So mysterious candy by the way, I'm a I'm an idiot. I'm mentioning in a previous episode and everyone freaked out just
Thought I'd mentioned that now that there's a little bit of loading time, and we don't really have anything to discuss
There's just a black screen really okay. Please be over. Thank you. Oh what?
We're back here. This is our first fart
When we were
We should be happy that he's made friends in this town so quickly we came here to hide more friends just means more trouble
You're being paranoid. You need to lay off that stuff. It's changing you
Thing that helps me relax from your stupid
It did seem like we weren't really finish
We were doing stop Mitch Conner catch up to yourself
Excuse me they
It appears here in northern timeline cozy own does not yet support
We're not playing superheroes dumbass come on you kid oh
Yeah, because we were the king yes, yes of course genius plot land
This isn't a dragon hey Frank fuck you dude. I'm great. We don't have time for this stand aside
We have to get to carbon well. You'll just have to get back on and our kick are we finding our past self
Good good. Good. Good good
Well we should be a lot stronger oh nevermind
This is why we didn't let girls play in the first place what in the world?
What does it do
I did nothing oh
I'm gonna relay
Yeah, no I'm gonna beat the crap out of myself
Never thought I'd say that
Right here, we are
fairly strong yeah
Big strongest warrior can handle these weirdos well. I mean okay special objective defeat warrior Clyde
What oh he's good
Why did the king stop
Okay Dan, that's a lie go need
This computer snap oh he's confused, and he kills his teammate. That's awesome. It's nice
And it's down that was easy very easy compared to everything else. We've done
Alright figured every more
We got to find all
Bündchen no chit sir
No, that's awesome
Defeat thief Craig, but he knows jujitsu
What if we possibly gonna did
All right now you know what I will, which one is the real well
Well not that one that's our but that was your buttonhole
Nice that was smooth as butter in your butt
More okay, I guess we're going through all of them. There's like the last big fight or some shoes
Rahr Rahr every
100 and so actually it is kind of like is it punishes a Jewish joke I don't know exactly how it works
Damn that sucks. I wish I could rewind that now use the gun I get it
And then a punch was that okay?
And he's gone I guess we have one more aha jeez
What no no no no no
Hopefully, they don't have full help at least
Because they look damaged right I mean look at them
They have full health okay great. Okay great. That's what I that's what I wanted. That's this is just what I want
This is great. I used the meteors again, which I can't block
That's great
They'd charge a lot of our old though
And was a pirate hamster or guinea pig
Microaggression
he called me a fat ass I
Forgot about the microaggressions, this is the best
I sort of went all in on just the king this time
And he's dead, but I actually think we have to kill everyone so that was kind of pointless oh
You worked okay great good good that that elven really looks like something else, okay? Let's get real here
Okay cool. I'm glad that stright worked. It was a bit riskier. Yes
Yeah, but we know how to
Kill him
Yes, I was just traveling back in time to find you a cat's missing
There's a big reward wait why you guys already playing superhero. We know what you're up
But you're with the freedom house. We're all freedom pals. We're from the future you fat turd no I'm from the future
I was just coming back to stick a tooth times to get you guys. We aren't playing anymore
We know everything like are they connected in her left hand my left hand, but when I was your fucking left hand
Hello freedom pass time travel ain't it a bitch Connor what the hell are you doing here?
I had a plan to use the new kid as means to get what I always wanted
But it looks like some do-gooders traveled back in time to stop me Cartman. I swear to god
It was it he Jennifer Lopez because I still know something you out don't what's that?
how to make someone fart super bad by hitting them in the solar plexus
What could possibly happen next
Well the game is black, so I don't know maybe Morgan Freeman welcome and savers Oh, No okay?
Here we are Connor we're in the time that a superhero was born recognize this place new kid. Yeah, oh
Why have you brought us here, don't you see this is the night new kid fateful night your dad fucked your mom
You walked to the mirror don't do this to him, but don't you see King?
This is what he wanted out alone to fix it oh
You heard your mother calling for help so you left your room
Don't you kid you can't change the past of course you can go look
Huh where oh sorry
Okay, don't you see new kid I've given you an opportunity
Which will you do new kid fight the bad guys again?
Fight your younger self so that you never have to witness what's behind your parents door
bad guys
We're just followers right you're the little kid with like a zillion followers, right we just thought well
We thought that if you could add us and maybe
Know maybe we could have friends because we don't really have any followers. Oh, please add us of course
Let's do oh boy selfie
Anything our moment moment is finally here Wow?
Yes, of course it's happening. That's happening. Let's do it smiley face. Oh
wow
James Paris we did everyone
Have a 3a in France or now that's incredible
See we did it. We did it everyone. Don't go through that door. Yeah, no
No no no no
Go back to bed, honey. Oh yeah our parents hate each other. Okay? You did it you stopped your dad
You saved your mom new hit that's right, and now there's nobody left to stop me. I'm off to another
10200 know who the hell are you I'm the king this is your kid from the future our child from the future oh
God I know something like this would happen our child knows. We've been lying and wants some answers. You're right kiddo. We've been dishonest
But only because we wanted to protect you
The truth is your mom and I have certain abilities
powers that normal humans don't have I
Discovered mine when I was younger
One day I created a facebook profile and within a few hours. I had over three million followers
My powers are similar except. They only seem to work on Instagram
I got four million followers as soon as I posted my first picture of course powers like that. Don't go unnoticed for long
shortly after that your mother
And I were kidnapped by the government where they had scientists spending months doing experiments on us try to figure out
How we were able to gain so many followers so fast
That's what your dad, and I met and fell in love huh Perrin inside a cold damp government lab
Yes, by day they ran experiments and by night
We made sweet love oh no my powers combined with your mother's you
Received over 10 million followers the minute you were born
and
By the time they cut the umbilical cord you were already more powerful than all the Cardassians combined
That's why we had to escape because we knew the government would use you to do horrible things
And we've been on the run ever since moving from city to city always trying to stay one step ahead
But everywhere we go you just can't seem to stop
Gaining followers that was about sometimes they even break into our house and use our toilet just to be close to you
That's why we've been putting special medicine in your dinner sweetie to try to curb your powers
But it didn't work the side effects of the medicine just gave you really
Powerful and really smelly it all makes sense doesn't it re kiddo. Oh my god
I feel so relieved to have finally told the truth me too, honey. I
You know I don't think I need to drink any more. I said I don't need to run from my problems with pop brownies
Oh, honey. I feel like your future is going to be totally different now. I believe in us
Yeah, God, but what about you sweetie now that you know the truth? Do do you think you can believe in yourself, too?
Leap through time really that's what we're getting okay now
Not like this oh sorry
It's bit anti-climatic when you do Lily just like you move anything and it
just stops
It's gonna really charge it at an energy
Press X to believe in yourself
Press F. We're suppress areas the Ephesus
I
Can downtown South Park, but where is everybody more importantly what period of time have we landed
We got a step
But why don't we just cut off your hand or something?
Stop Mitch Connors inauguration, yeah
Can't let that happen
Are we gonna be like those salty Trump supporters, I mean
You're not going anywhere
You are Mitch Conner admit it Carmen. No. I'm not how admit it no ciao. I have no control over Mitch Conner
You are Mitch Conner. You've always been Mitch Conner, and you better stop right fucking now, then how do you explain this?
I'm not doing it. Dude. Fuck you. What's the matter cane shoes on the other hand how fucking knock it off
Why are you pissed at him because he's fucking making it up. That's why I'm not making it up, dude
That's your fucking hand as hosts. Not fucking charlie me. How does he trailing you kid?
He's trying to teach me a lesson about being deceitful wait
So you admit you were making it up before see this is a troll to get me to admit. I was rolling you guys
This is just when I run it all the Coon friends at each other's throats dude come on are you doing that yeah?
Which means maybe Cartman was just doing it before well, will you admit it Cartman you see proves it see what he's doing right?
I have no fucking idea. Oh how one little issue of mistrust can rip a team apart well, Freedom Pass
Who do you attack me or the king?
Why in the world
I'm not doing it
Bullshit mr.. Maddock kun. You're not happy to see me fuck you cap this is sad. It's pretty confusing at this point. I don't
Any damage I take goes to the king
I can't do it
Well I got rules too, buddy
They're gonna be me or the Keene, I don't
Oh no no no no fucking deflects
Okay, so anything damaged I do hits kyun anyway, it's
How about you Freedom House, which one of us is the real villain
In feed
Your up who you're gonna fight freedom now. I'm really open to hitting either of you. Uh-huh
same I can't attack I
Have a really good feeling about this gasps
We have to finish Khan egg kun, and then we can finish Kyle I think
Oh
My god
No
Doesn't heal
What what
My brain
my brain everybody
classic, Michigan I
Don't know I really don't know I
Feel like if Kyle wasn't trolling he would have just stopped us by now
Okay same switch
This is oh my god
What is going on
I kind of agree ha ha ha
At the same time
Yes
Help us, what wait wait wait wait wait dr. Timothy calls no cheating go okay?
Nice look at that oh oh oh Connors it is same
Haha, thank fucking god. Oh my god
Tell these guys you were just fucking with me, they're gonna just keep beating the shit out of both of us, yeah, dude
Kyle if you're just fucking with us we have to know you're just making things more confusing
If I was just fucking with you, then so is he right
Oh, I see, I'll admit. I was just fucking with you guys, but only if Kyle admits you at first
I'm not seeing anything until he does you admit it first all right fine
We'll both admitted at the same time all right Bogg three. We're both saying. I was just fucking with you
I was surprised
For too long our town has been led by a
dumbass bitch mayor who never did anything to stop crime and now Mitch Carter's gonna
Talking just make me mayor already. It's Mitch corner
We made it
To begin the inauguration mr. Connor, would you raise your right hand please?
Yeah
I do solemnly swear a do solemnly swear
What's going on here just finish the ceremony
everyone listen
this is all just a plan to get more crime in our town so that the Coon and friends franchise would be bigger than the
freedom pal franchise
of course
Ma'am except Sharon has been put into your drugs and alcohol to raise crime in the city so that the Coon would have more crime
To fight everything was thought up by then asshole
Mitch Conner rads a fat raccoon
No, don't you get it? He did it all go ahead, and you kid show them the selfie you tuck
Show them this sip
Which was that that was that let me just show it to me, and I'll put it on Connors Instagram for everyone to see
It's uploaded there we go. I'm glad the Coons two gram actually had some sort of purpose
You mean he was putting poison in our wine and cocaine
Yeah
I'll tell you that because the new kid isn't the only person who had a parent get fucked
My dad got fucked when I was nine years old
Only two people on this stage know how that feels
Not already Shh. I want to hear this my father will be avenged even if it means everyone else has to die
Mitch Mitch it's over. Ha ha ha ha ha
I've been here
It's not your fault Mitch
What are you talking about? It was me Mitch. I'm the one who fucked your day
I
Didn't I wanted a future for you how these years hunting for the person that fucked my dad
And it was my own mother Mitch try and stay calm fuck you you may be really cute
But even you can't fix this did he look at you ma'am
Did he look you in the eye when he snuck up and fucked him?
Please tell me you're not buying into this I didn't kill you for what you did
Well that guy isn't gonna be mayor come on everybody let's go
Yes, oh that was it right
Sister
Oh my god
What an ending, but I got damnit knee oh
My god so
I
Love the whole Mitch counter thing it's so dumb
Okay, like I would old tied it together. You know that Kunta Graham the time travel
Connor and the backstory that was brilliant, man
It's funny. How you know such a complex thing like time travel is done
It's usually done so poorly in movies, but they you know something like South Park. That's so silly and they really nailed it
I was so good
Yeah, I know they aint got me man, I will say like
Some parts I find the game to be a bit. Oh, okay. I'll give my final thoughts after this
Playing with your friends honey. This is a great town. Isn't it? I love it here
I'm so glad that all those years ago. We came clean about our child's past
I feel like all those years among like our lives are different now somehow I
Love you, and I love you
They're not gonna have sex are they in fact
Kiddo, would you excuse us for a moment Oh mommy and daddy have a little business to take care of upstairs?
Oh, you know my god
Don't walk in there little kid oh
Don't do it no
Did you really think you could stop bad things from happening now. It was underneath the glass
Catches up with you he's driving
There's only one truth of Miss Maggie no matter, how hard you try to change the past
You've got a house
Okay, so that's the official?
Okay
So I don't know I think the first game was so good that my expectations for this was you know way higher
obviously, and I think since it was delayed so much a lot of the
Anticipation for it to come out really brewed up a lot, and I think that even made it even worse almost
so my expectation was so high when I played it and
It has a lot of issues the game is really glitchy
I
Mean I had to restart the game a couple of times which is more than most games these days at least
I mean I understand some glitches, but you know there was lip-syncing issues all the time
Loading screens was just atrocious man
I know that's a console thing I would but I hear that's a big glitch here on the PC
So it's just a shame. It just kind of sours your experience a little bit I
found that
It was maybe because I didn't do enough sidequest maybe but a lot of the times
I just felt like it's a lot of walking from here to there all the buddy system
I found to be kind of annoying it just felt like alright. I get it
but that
obviously
the times were it shined it really did and it was so funny and everything that you love about South Park really came through and
It made it worth it. It made it like a really really good game like that ending got me so good. I was hilarious
Still I've been just thinking about it, but I mean
It we made up right. I was saying. I really really enjoyed it regardless
and I can't wait and I really hope they'll make another game because
They really I think they still really did a great job
And I hope they will find maybe the issues with this game and improve upon because they can definitely be adjusted
Other than that thank you guys so much for watching this let's play our playthrough walkthrough alright now, but with me
It's a lot of fun. I really really really enjoyed it. It's been a long time since we had a long play through
Every single day it was a lot of extra
Especially since I don't have internet. I keep having to like well. It doesn't matter, but it was them
It was nice
It brought me back to like and all the time of the channel, and I hope in maybe not too far in the future
We'll do another one because it's a lot of games coming out now for Christmas as well, so we'll see you know. We'll see
But it really means a lot that you guys stuck through this with me, and I hope you enjoyed yourself as well
And I will if anything I'll see you back with the daily videos and in the next let's play. Thank you guys and quite fan